The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SURYA GANGULI: I'm going to
talk about statistical physics
of deep learning, essentially.
So this is some
ongoing work in my lab
that was really
motivated by trying
to understand how neural
networks and infants learn
categories.
And then it sort of led
to a bunch of results
in deep learning that
involved statistical physics.
So I wanted to just introduce
my lab a little bit.
I'm an interloper
from the Methods
in Computational
Neuroscience Summer School
where I tend to spend a month.
And so there, you know,
the flavor of research
that we do there and the flavor
of research we do in our lab
is sort of drilling down into
neural mechanisms underlying
well-defined computations.
And we've been working on that.
You know, I spent a
lot of time talking
to neurophysiologists especially
at Stanford where I am.
So we have a whole
bunch of collaborations
going on now involving
understanding
neural computation.
So, for example,
the retina itself
is actually a deep
neural circuit already,
because there's an
intervening layer of neurons,
the bipolar cells
and amacrine cells,
that intervene between the
photoreceptors and the ganglion
cells.
And oftentimes, what
we do is we shine light
on the photo receptors and we
measure the ganglion cells,
but we have no clue what's
going on in the interior.
So we've developed computational
methods that can successfully
computationally
reconstruct what's
going on in the interior of this
putative deep neural network
even though we don't have
access to these things.
And we actually infer the
existence and properties
of intermediate neurons here.
And those properties are
sort of similar to what's
been previously recorded when
people do directly record
from, say, the bipolar cells.
In the Clandinin
Lab, we've sort of
been unraveling the computations
underlying a motion vision.
So you know when you swat
a fly, it's really hard.
Because they can
really quickly detect
motion coming towards it.
And they fly away.
You know, so there's
been lots of work
on what kinds of
algorithms might underlie
motion estimation-- for
example, the Reichardt
correlator the, Barlow-Levick
model and so forth.
We've been applying systems
identification techniques
to whole brain
calcium imaging data--
well, whole brain meaning
from the fly visual circuit.
And we just literally
identify the computation.
And we find that it's
sort of none of the above.
It's a mixture of all
previous approaches.
So grid cells-- we have
some results on grid cells.
So these are these famous cells
that resulted in a Nobel Prize
recently.
We can actually show that
these grid cells maintain
their spatial coherence,
because the rat and the mouse
are always interacting
with the boundaries.
And the boundaries
actually correct the rat's
internal estimate of position.
And were it not for
these interactions
with the boundaries, the
grid cells would rapidly
decohere on the time
scale of minutes,
you know, like
less than a minute.
And so it's actually
quite interesting.
We can show that whenever the
rat encounters a boundary,
it corrects its internal
estimate of position
perpendicular to the boundary.
But it doesn't parallel.
And it doesn't,
because it can't.
Because when it
hits the boundary,
it receives no information
about where it is parallel
to the boundary, but it receives
information in this direction.
And then with the
Shenoy Lab, we've
been looking at I think a
really major conceptual puzzle
in neuroscience.
Why can we record from 100
neurons in a circuit containing
millions of neurons?
And do dimensionality detection
and try to infer the state
space dynamics of
the circuit and claim
that we've achieved
success, right?
We're doing dramatic
undersampling recording
100 neurons out of millions.
How would the state space
dynamics that we infer change
if we recorded more neurons?
And we can show
that, essentially, it
will not change.
Because we've come up
with a novel connection
between the act of
neural measurements
and the act of
random projections.
So we can show that
the act of recording
from 100 neurons in the brain
is like the act of measuring
100 random linear
combinations of all neurons
in the relevant brain circuit.
And then we can apply
random projection theory
to give us a predictive
theory of experimental design
that tells us, given the
complexity of the task, how
many neurons would you need
to record to correctly recover
the state-space
dynamics of the circuit.
And then in the Raymond
Lab at Stanford,
we've been looking at how
enhancing synaptic plasticity
can either enhance
or impair learning
depending on experience.
So, for example, we think
that synaptic plasticity
underlies the very basis of our
ability to learn and remember.
So you might think that
enhancing synaptic plasticity
through various pharmacological
or genetic modifications
might enhance our ability
to learn and remember.
But previous results
have been mixed.
When you perturb
synaptic plasticity,
sometimes you enhance learning,
sometimes you impair learning.
So I believe in the
Raymond Lab, they're
the first to show that in
the same subject enhancing
syntactic plasticity,
for example,
in the cerebellum
can either enhance
or impair learning
depending on the history
of prior experience.
And we can show that in order to
explain the behavioral learning
curves, you need much more
complex postsynaptic dynamics
than people naturally assume.
We have to really promote our
notion of what a synapse is
from a single scalar, like
a WIJ at a neural network
to an entire dynamical
system in its own right.
So this relates to VOR learning.
So this is sort of the low-level
stuff that we've been doing.
I know that in this course you
guys study higher level stuff.
So I'm not going to
talk about any of these.
Each of them could be
like a one hour talk.
But I wanted to discuss
some more high level
stuff that we've been doing.
Oh, sorry.
And sorry, the other sort
of direction in our lab
that we're looking
at is actually
the statistical mechanics of
high dimensional data analysis.
So this is, of course,
very relevant in the age
of the BRAIN Initiative and
so on where we're developing
very large scale
data sets and we'd
like to extract theories
from this so-called big data.
So the entire edifice
of classical statistics
is predicated on the assumption
that you have many, many data
points and you have a small
number of features, right?
So then it's very easy to
see patterns in your data.
But what's actually
happening, nowadays,
is that we have a large
number of data points
and a large number of
features-- so for example,
where you can record from 100
neurons using electrophysiology
maybe for only 100
trials of any given trial
type in a monkey
doing some task.
So the ratio of the amount of
data to the number of features
is something that's order one.
So you know, the data
sets are like three points
in a three-dimensional space.
That's the best
we can visualize.
So it's a significant
challenge to do data analysis
in this scenario.
So it turns out there's
beautiful connections
between machine
learning and data
analysis and the statistical
physics of systems
of quenched disorder.
So what I mean by that
is in data analysis
you want to learn
statistical parameters
by maximizing the log
likelihood of the data given
the parameters.
In statistical physics,
you often want to minimize.
You know, this can be viewed
as energy minimization.
And so there's beautiful
connections between these.
And so we work on that.
So we've applied this
to compressed sensing.
We've applied this
to the problem
of what's the optimal inference
procedure in a regime,
in a high-dimensional regime.
We know that maximum likelihood
is optimal in this regime.
But something else is
better in this regime.
And we found what's better.
It turns out to be a
smooth maximum likelihood.
And, of course,
we've applied this
to a theory of neural
dimensionality and measurement.
So, you know, there's lots
of beautiful interactions
between physics, machine
learning, and neuroscience.
And, you know, this school
is a lot about that.
If you're interested, actually,
we wrote like a 70-page review
on statistical mechanics
of complex neural systems
and high-dimensional data.
We cover a whole bunch of
things like spin glasses,
the statistical mechanics of
learning, random matrix theory,
random dimensionality
reduction, compressed sensing,
and so on and so forth.
It was our attempt
to sort of put
some systematic order on
the diversity of topics
viewed through the lens
of statistical physics.
But what do I want
to talk about today?
And why did I decide to
branch out in the direction
that I'm going to
tell you about?
Well, I think there's
lots of motivations
for the alliance between
theoretical neuroscience,
theoretical machine learning
that lead to opportunities
for physics, and
math, and so on.
So this is the question that
should haunt all of us, right?
The question is,
what does it even
mean to understand
how the brain works
or how a neural circuit works?
OK?
You know, that's
an open question
that we really have
to come to terms with.
A more concrete version
of this question might be,
or a specification
of this question
might be, we will understand
this when we understand
how the connectivity and
dynamics of a neural circuit
give rise to behavior and
also how neural activity
and synaptic learning
rules conspire
to self-organize useful
connectivity that
subserves behavior.
OK?
So, you know, various
BRAIN Initiatives
are promising to
give us recording
some large numbers
of neurons and even
give us the connectivity
between those neurons.
Now, what have theorists done?
Often what theorists in
computational neuroscience
do is they often develop
theories of random networks
that have no function.
But what we would
like to do is we'd
like to understand engineered
networks that have function.
So the field of machine learning
has generated a plethora
of learned neural
networks that accomplish
interesting functions.
Yet we still don't have a
meaningful understanding
of how their connectivity,
dynamics, the learning rule,
the developmental experience--
OK.
So basically, we
can measure anything
we want in these artificial
neural networks, right?
We can measure all
the connectivity
between all the neurons.
We know the dynamics
of all the neurons.
We know the learning rule.
We know the entire developmental
experience of the network,
because we know the training
data that it was exposed to.
Yet we still do not have
a meaningful understanding
of how they learn
and how they work.
And if we can't solve that
problem, how are we ever going
to understand the brain, right,
in the form of this question?
OK?
So that was sort of
what was motivating
me to look into this.
So this is the
outline of the talk.
The original entry
point was trying
to understand category
learning in neural networks.
And then at the
end of the day, we
made actually several
theoretical advances
that led to advances in machine
learning and applications
to engineering.
So, for example, we found
random weight initializations
that make a network
dynamically critical
and allow very,
very rapid training
of deep neural networks.
We were able to
understand and exploit
the geometry of high-dimensional
error surfaces to, again, speed
up learning, like training
deep neural networks.
And we were also able to
exploit sort of recent work
in non-equilibrium
thermodynamics
to learn complex probabilistic
generative models.
So it's a diversity of topics,
but I'll walk you through them.
And, you know, you can relax,
because almost everything
I'm going to talk
about is published.
OK.
So let's start with
the motivation,
a mathematical theory
of semantic development.
I think this speaks to some
of the high level stuff
that you guys think about.
This part could be
called the misadventures
of an applied physicists
who found himself lost
in the psychology department.
So I just sort of
showed up at Stanford.
Jay's a great guy.
I was talking to him.
And I learned about his work.
And I realized it
didn't understand it.
And this is my attempt
to understand that work
with Andrew and Jay.
OK.
So what is semantic cognition?
So human semantic cognition, a
rough definition of this field,
is that we have an ability to
learn, recognize, comprehend,
and produce inferences
about properties of objects
and events in the
world, especially
properties that are not present
in your current perceptual
stimulus.
So, for example, I can
ask you does a cat fur
and do birds fly, and you
can answer these questions
correctly despite the fact
that there's currently no cat
or bird in the room, right?
So, you know, our
ability to do this likely
relies on our ability to
form internal representations
of categories in the external
world and associate properties
with those categories.
Because we never see
the same stimulus twice.
So whenever we
see a new stimulus
or we try to recall
information from our brain,
we rapidly identify
the relevant category
that contains the information.
And we use that
categorical representation
to guide future actions
or give answers.
So category formation is
central to this, right?
So what are the kinds
of psychophysical tasks
that people use to probe
semantic cognition?
So this is a very rich field.
Psychologists have been
working on this all the time.
So one example is
looking time studies
to ascertain whether
or not an infant can
distinguish between two
categories of objects
at what age.
So, for example, they'll
show a sequence of objects
from category one, say, horses.
And the first time the infant
sees a horse, the looking time
will go up.
And then it goes down over time.
It gets bored.
Then you show a cow.
And if the infant is old
enough, the looking time
will go up and
then go back down.
And from that, we infer that
the infant can distinguish
between horses and cows.
But if it's not old enough, the
looking time will not go up.
So as the infant
gets older and older,
it can make more and more
fine scale discriminations
between categories it turns out.
So property verification tasks--
you can ask, can a canary move?
Can it sing?
And certain questions
are answered quickly.
Certain questions
are answered late,
which speaks to
certain properties
being central and peripheral
to certain categories.
Category membership queries--
is a sparrow a bird,
or is an ostrich a bird?
Again, there's
different latencies.
And that suggests that there are
typical and atypical category
members.
And also, very,
very important to us
is inductive generalization.
We can both generalize familiar
properties to novel objects--
for example, a
blick has feathers.
Does it fly?
Does it sing?
And we can generalize novel
properties to familiar objects.
A bird has gene x.
Does a crocodile have gene x?
Does a dog have gene x?
You know, so people have
measured these patterns
of inductive generalizations.
And there's various
theories that try
to explain all of this stuff.
So Jay has been working on this
stuff from a neural network
perspective.
And he wrote a beautiful book
called Semantic Cognition where
he uses neural
networks to explain
a whole variety of
phenomena especially,
for example, the progressive
differentiation of concepts.
So let me just walk
you through that.
And so this was, you
know, a first encounter
with a deep neural network.
So they were doing
deep neural networks
before they became popular.
And so what they were
doing was they asked,
can we model the development
of, say, concepts in infants?
And so what they did
was they had a toy data
set where they had
a bunch of objects
and each object had a
whole bunch of properties.
So, for example, a canary can
grow, move, fly, and sing,
right?
And so what they
did was they exposed
this deep neural network to
training data of this form.
You know, they had a
whole bunch of features
and questions and objects.
And they just exposed the
network to training data,
trained it using
back propagation.
And they looked at the internal
representations in the network,
especially their evolution over
developmental time or training
time, right?
And this is what they found.
So initially, the network
started with random weights.
So there was no structure.
OK.
So what did they do here?
They looked at the distances
between the internal
representations in this space.
And they did hierarchical
clustering or multidimensional
scaling.
And they found these plots
or these plots, right?
So what you see is, early
in developmental time,
the network first makes a
coarse-grain discrimination
between animals
and plants, right?
And then later, it makes
finer scale discriminations.
And then eventually
when it's fully learned,
it learns the hierarchical
structure that's
implicit in the training data.
OK.
And this is a
multidimensional scaling plot
where initially the animals
move away from the plants,
and then, you know, fish
move away from birds,
and trees move
away from flowers.
And then finally, individual
discriminations are learned.
So when I learned about
this, I was at once excited
and also mystified.
Because this is sort
of qualitatively
behaving like the way
that an infant behaves,
yet it's a really stupid neural
network with like five layers.
Yet I don't understand how
it's doing this, right?
So I wanted a theory of
what's going on here, right?
Oh and by the way,
you know, there's
lots of reasons to believe
that semantic relationships are
encoded in the brain using
relatively simple metrics
like Euclidean distance
between neural representations
for different objects.
So, for example, this
is a famous study
which I'm sure you've seen.
What they showed
was a whole bunch
of objects to both
monkeys and humans.
And they clustered the objects
or looked at similarity matrix
of the objects measured
using a Euclidean distance
in neural
electrophysiology space,
so fine rates of neurons
here and voxel activity
patterns in the human.
And they showed the same set
of objects to monkey and human.
And the matrices
aligned, essentially.
So basically, the
similarity structure
of internal representations
of both monkey and human
is the same.
So we tend to encode
semantic information using
the similarity representations.
So this is the hierarchical
clustering view.
So this sort of seems
to actually happen
in real live animals and humans.
OK.
There's actually something
else that happens.
It's that different properties
are learned on different time
scales.
So, for example, the
network can learn
that canaries can move
much more quickly than it
learns that a canary is yellow.
So some properties are much
easier to learn than others.
And the properties that are
easier to learn for the network
are also easier to
learn for the infant.
OK.
So these are the theoretical
questions we'd like to answer.
What are the
mathematical principles
underlying the hierarchical
self-organization
of internal representations
in the network?
You know, this is
a complex system.
So what are the relative roles
of the various ingredients?
There's a non-linear
input-output response.
There's a learning rule,
which is back propagation.
There's the input statistics.
Is the network somehow reaching
into complex input statistics
in the training set,
or can it really
rely on just second
order statistics?
You know, what is a mathematical
definition of something
called category coherence?
And how does it relate to the
speed of category learning?
So what determines the speed
at which we learn categories?
Why are some properties learned
more quickly than others?
And how can we explain
changing patterns
of inductive generalization over
these developmental timescales?
OK.
So how do we get a theory?
Well, it turns out if you
look at the activations
of this network as it's
training over time,
so these are sigmoidal units.
And the activations don't
really hit the saturating regime
that much during
training, because you
start from small weights.
So we started with
an audacious proposal
that maybe even a linear
neural network might exhibit
this kind of learning dynamics.
OK?
Now, it's not at all
obvious that it should,
because it's a simple
linear neural network.
And this learning dynamics
is highly non-linear, right?
But it turns out that even
in a linear neural network,
the dynamics of learning
on synaptic weight space
is non-linear.
And so there might be a
hope that it might work
and we might be able to
get a coherent theory.
OK.
So what we did was we analyzed
just a simple linear neural
network that looks like this
that goes from input layer
to hidden layer to output layer.
So the composite map is linear.
OK.
So we can write down
dynamical equations and weight
space for the learning dynamic.
So this is the training data.
And we can adjust the weights
using back propagation.
And these are the back
propagation equations.
And if we work in a limit
where the learning is slow
relative to the time it takes
to cycle through the data set,
you can take a
continuous time limit,
and you essentially get a
non-linear set of equations
in weight space, right?
And the equations are cubic
in the weights, right?
And that's because the error is
quartic in the weights, right?
The error is the output minus
w, w times the inputs squared.
So the error is
quartic in the weights.
And so if you can
differentiate the weights
on the right-hand side, the
gradient descent equations
will be cubic in the weights.
But there is one
simplification that happens.
Because the network
is linear, it's
learning dynamics is sensitive
only to the second order
statistics of the data, right?
So in particular--
the input-input
covariance matrix and the
input-output covariance matrix.
OK.
So essentially, this
network knows only
about second order statistics.
In our work here, the
input statistics is white.
So it's really only the
input-output statistics
that drives learning.
OK?
So this is a set of coupled
non-linear differential
equations.
They're, in general,
hard to solve.
But we found solutions to them.
We can express the solutions
in terms of the singular value
decomposition of the
input-output covariance matrix.
You know, any rectangular matrix
has a unique singular value
decomposition.
In this context,
we can think about
the input-output covariance
matrix as a matrix
that maps input objects
to feature attributes.
And the singular vectors
have an interpretation
where these singular vectors
essentially map objects
into internal representations.
The singular values
amplify them.
And then the columns of you are
sort of feature synthesizers.
The columns are sort of modes
in the output feature space.
OK.
So this is the SVD.
But the question
is, how does this
drive the learning dynamics?
So what we did was we
found exact solutions
to the learning
dynamics of this form
where the product
of the layer one
to layer two weights and
the layer two to layer three
weights are of this form.
Where, essentially, the
system, what it's doing--
the composite system-- is
building up the singular value
decomposition of the
input-output covariance matrix
mode by mode.
And each mode alpha, associated
with singular value alpha
in the training data,
is being learned
in the sigmoidal fashion.
OK?
So at time zero, A is
sort of small and random,
you know, some initial
condition A zero.
But over time, as time
training time goes to infinity,
the A approaches the
actual singular value
in the input-output
covariance matrix.
So basically, this is
the learning dynamic.
So nothing happens for a while.
And then suddenly, the
strongest singular mode
defined by the largest
single value gets learned.
And then later on, a smaller
singular mode gets learned.
And later on, an even smaller
And the time it takes
to learn each mode
is governed by one over
the singular value.
So just intuitively, stronger
statistical structure
as quantified by singular
value is learned first.
That's the intuition.
Often time when we
train neural networks,
we see sort of these
plateaus in performance
where the network does nothing
and then suddenly drops,
plateaus and drops.
And this actually shows that.
You can see very, very sharp
transitions in learning.
And you can actually show that
the ratio of the transition
period to the ignorance period
can be arbitrarily small.
Infants also seem to show these
developmental transitions.
OK.
So, yeah, you can have
arbitrarily sharp transitions
in the system.
OK.
So the take-home messages
so far is the network
learns different modes of
covariation between input
and output on time scale
inversely proportional
to the statistical strength
of that covariation.
And you can get these sudden
transitions in learning.
Now the question
is, what does this
have to do with the hierarchical
differentiation of concepts?
All right, that's what we'd
like to understand first.
So now we've come up with a
general theory of learning,
the non-linear
dynamics of learning
in these deep circuits.
Now we want to connect this
back to hierarchical structure.
So one of the things
with Jay's work
is that we're just working
with toy data sets.
And we didn't have any
theoretical control
over those toy data sets.
But we sort of
understood implicitly
that these toy data sets
have hierarchical structure.
So we need a generative
model of data,
a controlled mathematically
well-defined generative
model of data that encodes
the notion of hierarchy.
OK?
So can we move beyond
specific data sets
to general principles
of what happens
when a neural network is exposed
to hierarchical structure?
That's what we'd like to answer.
So we consider a hierarchical
generative model.
And a classic hierarchical
generative model is--
yeah, so essentially
what we want to do
is we want to connect the
world of generative models
to the world of neural networks.
And, you know, that
will connect the methods
in computational neuroscience to
this course eventually, right?
Yeah.
So we have data generated
by some generative model.
We take that data, and we
expose it to a neural network.
And we'd like to understand
how the dynamics of learning
depends on the parameters
of the generative model.
OK.
So a natural generative
model for defining
hierarchical structure is a
branching diffusion process
that essentially mimics the
process of evolution where
properties diffuse down a tree
and instantiate themselves
across a set of items.
So what do I mean by that?
OK.
So basically
imagine, for example,
that your items are at the
leaves of a tree, right?
And you can imagine that this
is a process of evolution where
there is some ancestral
state maybe for one property.
So we do one property at a time.
And the properties are
independent of each other.
This might be an ancestral
state like can move, right?
And then each time this
property diffuses down the tree,
there's a probability
of flipping, OK?
So maybe in this lineage which
might correspond to animals,
this doesn't flip, right?
And in these lineages
corresponding to plants,
it does flip.
So these things cannot move.
And these things can move.
And then maybe it doesn't flip.
So all of these things inherit
the property of moving.
So these are the animals.
And these things cannot move.
So these are the plants.
And then we do that for every
single property independently.
And we generate a set
of feature vectors.
So that's our generative model.
So what are the
statistical properties
of the generative model?
So essentially, because
we know that we're
analyzing these
deeper linear networks
and we know that the learning
dynamics of such networks
is driven only by the
input-output covariance matrix,
to understand the
learning dynamics
we just have to compute the
singular values and singular
vectors of hierarchically
structured data generated
in this fashion.
And it's actually quite--
I mean, we did it.
So here's what happened.
So imagine a nice
symmetric tree like this.
So these are objects.
If we look at the similarity
structure of objects measured
by dot product in the feature
space generated by the features
under this branching
diffusion process,
we get this nice blocks within
blocks similarity structure
where all the items
on this branch--
you know this item and this
item-- are slightly similar.
This item and this item
are even more similar.
And, of course, each item
is most similar to itself.
So you have this
hierarchical hierarchy
of clusters that
naturally arise because
of this branching
diffusion process.
So what are the singular
values and singular
vectors of the associated
input-output covariance matrix?
Well, they turn out these are
one set of singular vectors,
the so-called object
analyzers, which
are functions across objects.
There's another set
of singular vectors
that are functions
across features,
which I'm not showing you.
But there's, of course,
the duality, right?
So that you get
pairs of singular
vectors for each single value.
OK.
So what's the singular vector
associated with the largest
singular value?
Well, it's a uniform mode
that's constant across all
the objects.
But the most interesting
one, the next largest one,
is the most lowest frequency
function, essentially.
It's constant along all the
ancestors of this branch
and a different
constant along all
the ancestors of this branch.
So this singular
vector, essentially,
makes the most coarse
grain discrimination
in this hierarchically
structured data set.
The next set of
singular vectors--
there's a pair of them--
discriminate between this set of
objects and this set of objects
and don't know about these ones.
And the next one discriminates
between this set of objects
and this set of objects.
And then as you go down to
the smaller singular values,
you get individual object
discriminations, right?
So this is how the
hierarchical structure
is reflected in the second
order statistics of the data.
And these are the
singular values.
So this is the theory for the
singular values in a tree that
has five levels of hierarchy.
And you can see that the
singular values decay
with the hierarchy level
of the singular vectors.
OK.
So there's a general
theory for this
in which singular
vectors are associated
with levels of the tree.
OK?
So now you can see
the end of the story.
If you put the two
together, you automatically
get the results that we were
trying to explain, right?
So essentially, the
general theory of learning
says that the network
learns input-output modes
on a time scale given by
1 over the singular value.
When the data is
hierarchically structured,
singular values of broader
hierarchical distinctions
are larger than singular
values of finer distinctions.
And the input-output
modes correspond exactly
to hierarchical
distributions of the tree.
So that essentially says the
network must learn broad scale
discriminations before
it can learn fine scale
discriminations.
So then actually what we did
was we just analytically worked
out that the dynamics of
learning for hierarchically
structured data.
And we computed the
multidimensional scaling.
And this was theory.
We never did a single
simulation to get this plot.
We generated a branching
diffusion process
that was essentially this one.
And we just labeled these nodes
arbitrarily with these labels.
And this is what we get, right?
So we see the
multidimensional scaling plot
that we sort of see here.
And essentially,
just to compare,
this is what was done with
a toy data set over which
we had no theoretical control
and a non-linear neural network
over which we had no
theoretical control.
And this is a well-defined
mathematical generative model
under a linear neural network.
And we see that we qualitatively
explain the results.
So this is the difference
between simulation and theory,
right?
Now we have a conceptual
understanding of effectively
what was going on
in this circuit.
And now, it's no
longer a mystery.
So now I think I understand
what Jay and collaborators were
doing.
It would be lovely if, for all
of the stuff that's going on
in this course, we
could obtain such
a deep rigorous understanding.
It's much more challenging.
But it's a goal worthy
of pursuit I think.
OK.
So conclusions--
progressive differentiation
of hierarchical structure
is a general feature
of learning in deep
neural networks.
It cannot be any other way.
OK?
Interestingly enough,
deep, but not shallow,
networks exhibit such stage-like
transitions during learning.
So if you just do
no hidden layers,
you don't get this, actually.
You need a hidden
layer to do this.
And somewhat
surprisingly, it turns out
that even only the
second order statistics
of semantic properties provide
powerful statistical signals
that are sufficient to drive
this non-linear learning
dynamics, right?
You don't need to look
at the higher order
statistics of the data
to get this dynamic.
Second order statistics
suffice, which was not obvious
before we started.
OK.
So in ongoing work,
we can explain
a whole bunch of things,
like illusory correlations
early in learning.
So, for example,
infants, they don't even
know that, for example, pine
trees don't have leaves.
Then at an intermediate
point, they
think that pine
trees have leaves.
And then at a later
point, they correctly know
that pine trees don't
have leaves, right?
So we can explain these
non-monotonic learning curves.
We can explain these familiarity
and typicality effects.
We can explain inductive
property judgments
analytically.
We're looking at
basic level effects.
We have a theory of category
coherence, and so on.
But in the interest
of moving forward,
I wanted to give short
shrift to this stuff.
And essentially, we
can answer why are
some properties learned faster?
Basically, properties
that are low frequency
properties on the leaves of
the tree get learned faster.
Properties whose inner
product with the singular
vector as a larger singular
value get learned faster.
That's the story.
Why are some items more typical?
We have a theory for that.
How is inductive generalization
achieved by neural networks?
We have a theory
for that and so on.
And, you know, what is a
useful mathematical definition
of category coherence?
So, for example, you know,
there are some things
that are just intuitively
called incoherent categories.
"The set of all things are blue"
is a very incoherent category.
In fact, it's so
incoherent we don't have
a name for such a category.
"The set of all
things that are dogs"
seems to be a very
coherent category.
And it's so coherent that we
have a well-known name for it.
The name's quite
short actually, too.
Actually, I wonder if
there's a theory where
shorter words correspond
to more coherent categories
and that's like an informative
or efficient representation
of category structure.
But anyways, we have a natural
definition of coherent category
that's precise enough
to prove a theorem
that coherent categories
are learned faster.
And actually, this also relates
to the size of the categories.
So frequency effects show up.
Anyways, so there's
a lot of stuff there.
But that was sort
of the entry point.
So now, what about
a theory of learning
in much deeper networks
that have many, many layers?
OK?
So, again, I'm going to
make a long story short,
because it's all published.
So you can read all the details.
But I wanted to give you
the spirit or the essence
or the intuition
behind the work.
OK.
So the questions we'd
like to answer are,
how does training
time scale with depth?
How should learning
rate scale with depth?
How do different
weight initializations
impact learning speed?
And what we'll do is once we
understand these theoretically,
we'll find certain
weight initializations
that correspond to critical
dynamics, which I'll define,
can aid deep learning
and generalization.
So the basic idea is in a
very, very deep neural network,
right, you have a vanishing,
exploding, or gradient problem.
And that's one of
the issues that
makes deep neural
network learning hard.
So if you're going
to back propagate
the error through
multiple layers,
the back propagation
operation is
a product of Jacobians
from layer to layer.
And that product of
Jacobians is fundamentally
a linear mapping, right?
So if the singular
values associated
with that linear mapping--
so essentially, if
the singular values
of the Jacobian in each layer
are large, bigger than one,
the product of
such matrices will
lead to a product matrix
that has singular values that
grow exponentially with depth.
Similarly, if the single
values are less than one,
they'll decay with depth, right?
So that's a vanishing
gradient in the latter case
and an exploding gradient
in the former case.
That seems to be one of
the major impediments
to understanding deep learning.
So what people
often did was they
tried to scale the matrices
to avoid this question, right?
So what they often do is they
initialize the weights randomly
so that W is a random
matrix where the elements W,
I, J, are IID and Gaussian with
a scale factor scaled precisely
so that the largest
eigenvalue of the Jacobian
or the back propagation
operator is one.
OK?
So that's like
scaling the system so
that if you place a random
error vector here, the desired
output minus the actual
output, and back propagate it
through a random
network, a error vector
will preserve its norm as
it's back propagated across.
And this is the famous
sort of Glorot and Bengio
initialization.
And it works pretty well for
depth four or five or whatever,
right?
OK.
So we would like a theory
of that for the learning
dynamics of that.
And as I said, there's no
hope for a complete theory
at the moment with
arbitrary non-linearities.
OK.
So what we're going
to do is we're
to analyze the
learning dynamics.
Just-- we'll get rid of
the non-linearities, right?
So, again, it might seem like
we're throwing the baby out
with the bathwater,
but we're actually
going to learn
something that helps us
to train non-linear networks.
OK.
So the basic idea
then is that we
have a network which is linear.
So y, the output, is a
product of weights, right?
OK.
So then the back propagation's,
again, just a product
of matrices, right?
The gradient dynamics
is non-linear
and coupled and non-convex.
And actually even in
this linear network,
you see plateaus and
sudden transitions, right?
And actually,
interestingly enough,
even in this very
deep linear network,
you see faster conversions from
pre-trained initial conditions,
right?
So basically, if you
start from random Gaussian
initial conditions, you get
slow learning for a while
and then sudden learning
here, relatively
sudden learning here.
Whereas, if you're
pre-train the network using
greedy unsupervised
learning, so this is the time
it takes to pre-train, you
get sudden learning and a drop
here.
So remember, if you go back
to the original Hinton paper,
this was the phenomenon
that started deep learning.
Greedy unsupervised
pre-training allows
you to rapidly train very,
very deep neural networks.
So the very empirical
phenomenon that
led to the genesis
of deep learning
was present already in deep
linear neural networks, right?
So deep linear neural
networks, in terms
of their expressive
power, are crappy.
Because the composition of
linear operations is linear.
They're not a good model
for deep non-linear networks
in terms of
input-output mappings.
But they're a surprisingly good
model, theoretical toy model,
for modeling the
dynamics of learning
in non-linear networks.
OK?
Because very important
phenomena also
arise in the deep
linear networks.
And we're focusing on
learning dynamics here.
OK.
So we can build intuitions
for the non-linear case
by analyzing the linear case.
OK?
So we went through the three
layer dynamics already.
What about the multiple
layer dynamics?
So, again, the Jacobian can back
propagate or explode, right?
OK.
So, again, I'm going to
make a long story short.
But what we find is
that if you take--
OK, I'll tell you
the final result.
What we find is that we find a
class of weight initializations
that allow learning
time to remain constant
as the depth of the
network goes to infinity.
Now, I'm measuring learning time
in units of learning epochs,
right?
So, obviously, to train a deep
neural network, very, very deep
neural network, it
just takes longer
to compute each gradient, right?
So in terms of real
time, of course,
the time will scale with
the depth of the network.
But you might imagine
in terms of number
of gradient evaluations, as the
network gets deeper and deeper,
it might take longer
and longer to train it.
And we show a class
of initial conditions
for which that's not true.
As the network gets
deeper and deeper,
the number of
gradient evaluations
you need to train the
network can remain constant
even as the depth
goes to infinity even
in a non-linear network.
OK.
So let me give you
intuition for why.
OK.
So, for example, in the
classical initialization,
this Glorot and
Bengio initialization
doesn't have that.
But our initialization does.
So basically what we did was--
we'll start off with
a linear networks.
We trained deep linear
networks on MNIST.
And we scaled that
depth like this, right?
And we started with random
Gaussian initial conditions
and then ran back
propagation, but scaled
random Gaussian initializations.
And we found that the training
time, as you might expect,
grew with depth.
This is training time
measured in number
of learning epochs or number
of gradient evaluations.
But here what we did
was we initialized
the weights using random
orthogonal weights, right?
And then we found
that the learning time
didn't grow with depth.
And also, if you pre-train it,
it doesn't grow with depth.
OK.
So there's a dramatically
different scaling and learning
time between random
Gaussian initialization
and random orthogonal
initialization.
Why?
OK?
And the answer is the following.
Let's think about the
back propagation operator.
Let's say you want to
back propagate errors
from the output to the input.
So the back propagation
operator in a linear network
is just the product of weights
throughout the entire network.
OK?
So if you do a random Gaussian
weight initialization here,
then this is a product of
random Gaussian matrices.
So to understand the statistical
properties of back propagation,
you need to understand
the statistical properties
of the singular value spectrum
of random Gaussian matrices.
There isn't really a
general theory for that,
but we can look at it
numerically and get intuition
for it.
So the basic idea is if you
have one random Gaussian
matrix, the singular values
of W are the eigenvalues of W
transpose W. That's a
famous distribution called
the Marchenko-Pastur
distribution.
And you know, they vary in
a range that's order one.
OK?
So if you back propagate
through one layer, you're fine.
You don't get vanishing
exponent gradients.
OK.
But if you look at the singular
values of a product of five
random Gaussian matrices,
the singular value spectrum
gets very distorted.
You've got a large
number of similar values
that are close to zero and
a long tail that, you know,
extends up to four.
OK.
But if you do 100 layers, you
get a very, very large number
of singular values
that are close to zero
and very much longer tail.
OK?
Now, this is a product of
random Gaussian matrices.
So if you feed a random
vector into this, on average,
it's norm will be preserved.
The vector's length
will not change.
But we know that preserving
the length of a vector
is not the same as
preserving angles
between all pairs of vectors.
OK.
So actually, the way that this
product of random Gaussian
matrices preserves the
norm of the gradient
is it does it in a
very anisotropic way.
It takes an error
vector at the output,
and it projects it into
a low dimensional space
corresponding to the singular
values that are large.
And then it amplifies
it in that space.
So the length is preserved,
but all error vectors
get projected onto a
low-dimensional space
and amplified.
So a lot of error information
is lost in a product
of random Gaussian matrices.
OK.
So that's why the Glorot and
Bengio initial conditions work
well up to five or
six or seven, but they
don't work well up
to depth, say, 100
or in recurrent neural
networks as well.
OK?
So what can we do?
Well, a simple
thing we can do is
we can replace the matrices,
these random matrices,
with orthogonal matrices.
OK?
So we know that all the singular
values of an orthogonal matrix
are one, every single one.
And the product of orthogonal
matrices is orthogonal.
So therefore, the back
propagation operator
has all of its singular
values equal to one.
And there's generalizations
of orthogonal matrices
to rectangular versions
when the layers
don't have the same number
of neurons in each layer.
OK?
So this is fantastic.
So this works really
well for linear networks.
OK.
But how does this generalize
to non-linear networks?
Because then you have a
product of Jacobians, right?
So what happens here?
OK.
So what is the
product of Jacobian?
OK.
So if we imagine how
either errors back
propagate to the front or
how input perturbations back
propagate to the end,
it's the same thing.
So it's easier to think
about forward propagation.
Imagine that you have an input
and you perturb it slightly.
How does the perturbation
grow or decay?
Well, what happens is there's a
linear expansion or contraction
due to W.
And then this nominator
is usually compressive.
So there's a
non-linear compression
due the diagonal Jacobian
passing through the point y's
non-linearity.
And then, again, linear
modification and non-linear
compression, linear
modification,
and non-linear compression.
OK?
So what we could do is just
simply choose these again
to be random
orthogonal matrices.
And then what happens
is the growth or decay
of perturbations-- and we scale
the random orthogonal matrices
by a scale factor to combat
the non-linear compression.
And then the dynamics of
perturbations is like this.
You rotate, linearly scale,
non-linearly compress, rotate,
linearly scale, non-linearly
compress, and so on.
That's essentially
the type of dynamics
that occurs in dynamically
critical systems that
are close to the edge of chaos.
You get this alternating phase
space expansion and compression
that's in different
dimensions at different times.
OK?
So now you can just
compute numerically
under that initialization.
How does the singular
value spectrum
of the product of
Jacobian scale?
And it scales beautifully.
So this is the scale factor
for the type of non-linearity
that we use, the hyperbolic
tangent non-linearity.
The optimal scale
factor in front
of the random orthogonal
matrix is one.
And you see when
you choose that--
this was 100 layers, I believe--
even for 100 layers,
that end to end Jacobian
and from the input to output
has a singular value spectrum
that remains within
the range of order one.
If g is even slightly
less than one,
the singular values
exponentially
vanish with depth.
If g is larger than
one, the singular
values grow, but actually not
as quickly as you'd think.
So this is the critically
dynamical regime
that at least preserves
not only the norm
of back propagated
gradients, but all angles
between pairs of
gradients, right?
So it's an isotropic
preservation
of error information from
the end of the network all
the way to the beginning.
OK?
So does it work?
And it works better than
other initializations even
in non-linear networks.
So we trained 30 layer
non-linear networks.
And the initialization
works better.
And so also, interestingly
enough, at this critical factor
you also achieve better
generalization error.
And we don't have a good
theory for that actually.
The test error and the training
error, of course, goes down.
OK.
So that's an
interesting situation
where a theory of
linear networks
led to a practical
training advantage
from non-linear networks.
OK.
So here's another
question that we had.
OK?
There's a whole world
of convex optimization.
We want our machine
learning algorithms
to correspond to
convex optimization,
so we can find the
global minimum.
And there are no local
minima to impede us
from finding the
global minimum, right?
That's conventional wisdom.
Yet the deep neural
network people
ignore this conventional wisdom
and train very, very deep
neural networks and don't worry
about the potential impediments
to the local minima.
They seem to find pretty
good solutions why.
OK?
Is the intuition
that local minima
are really an impediment
to non-linear non-convex
optimization in high
dimensional spaces really true?
OK?
And you might
think that it's not
true for the following
intuitive reason, right?
So, again, it's often
thought that local minima,
at some high level of
error and training error,
stand as a major impediment
to non-convex optimization.
And, you know, this
is an example--
a two-dimensional caricature
of a protein folding energy
landscape.
And it's very rough, so there's
many, many local minima.
And the global minima
might be hard to find.
And that's true.
If you sort of draw
random generic surfaces
over low dimensions,
those random surfaces
will have many local minima.
But, of course, our
intuition about geometry
derived from our experience
with a low-dimensional world
is woefully inadequate for
thinking about geometry
in high-dimensional spaces.
So it turns out that random
non-convex error functions
over high-dimensional
spaces, local minima
are sort of exponentially
rare in the dimensionality
relative to saddle points.
Just intuitively,
imagine you have an error
function over 1,000 variables,
say 1,000 synaptic weights
in a deep network.
That's a small, deep network.
But anyways, let's say there's
a point at which the gradient
and weight space vanishes.
So now there's 1,000
directions in weight space
you could move away
from that extreme.
What are the chances that
every single direction you move
has positive curvature, right?
If it's a fairly
generic landscape,
the answer is exponentially
small in the dimensionality.
Some directions will
have negative curvature.
have positive curvature,
unless your critical point
is already at the bottom.
In that case, most directions
will have positive curvature.
Or unless your critical
point is at the top higher,
then most directions will have
negative curvature, right?
So statistical physicists
have made this intuition very
precise for random landscapes.
And they've developed
a theory for it.
So this is a paper
in Physical Review
Letters by Bray and Dean.
So what they did
was they imagined
just a random Gaussian
error landscape.
So what they did was they looked
at an error landscape that's
a continuous function
over n dimensions,
but there is correlations.
It's correlated over
some length scale.
So it's a single draw from a
random Gaussian process where
the kernel of the
Gaussian process
is falling off with
some length scale.
So the error at 0.1 is
correlated with the error
at 0.2 over some length scale.
And that correlation
falls off smoothly.
So it's a random
smooth landscape.
OK.
So the correlations
are local, essentially.
And then what they did was they
asked the following question.
Let x be a critical
point, a point where
the gradient vanishes.
OK?
We can plot every
single critical point
in a two-dimensional
feature space.
What is that feature space?
Well, the horizontal
axis is the error level
of the critical point.
At how high on the error axis
does this critical point sit?
And then this f is the fraction
of negative eigenvalues
of the Hessian at
that critical point.
So it's the fraction
of directions
that curve downwards.
OK.
So now a priori, critical
points could potentially
set anywhere in this
two-dimensional feature space,
right?
It turns out they don't.
They concentrate on a
monotonically increasing
curve that looks like this.
So the higher the error
level of the critical point,
the more the negative
curvature directions you have.
OK?
And to be an order one
distance away from this curve,
the probability
of that happening
is exponentially small in the
dimensionality of the problem.
OK?
Now, what does that mean?
It automatically
implies that there
are no local minima
at high error,
or at least they're
exponentially
rare relative to saddle
points of a given index.
OK?
So basically, you typically
never encounter local minima
at height error, right?
That would be stuff
that sits here.
And there's nothing here.
OK?
Second, if you are a
local minimum, which
means on this axis
you're at the bottom,
then your error level
must be very, very close
to the global minimum.
OK?
So if you get stuck
in a local minimum,
you're already close in
error to the global minimum.
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
this last element?
SURYA GANGULI: Yeah.
So if you're a local
minimum, your error level
will be close to the error
level the global minimum.
AUDIENCE: Why?
SURYA GANGULI: Because what does
it mean to be a local minimum?
It means that f is zero.
The fraction of negative
curvature eigenvalues
of the Hessian is zero.
And this is the
distribution of error levels
of such critical points.
They're strongly
peaked at this value,
which is the value of
the global minimum.
Essentially, there's
nothing out here.
OK?
All right, now in physics there
is this well-known principle
called universality.
There are certain
questions whose answers
don't depend on the details.
For example, certain
critical exponents
in the liquid-gas
phase transition
are exactly the same
as critical exponents
in the ferromagnetic
phase transition.
Because the symmetry
and dimensionality
of the order parameter
density in the case
of liquid and magnetization
in the case of ferromagnets
are the same.
So there's certain
questions whose answers
don't depend on the detail.
They only depend on the
symmetry and dimensionality
of the problem.
So one might think that
this qualitative prediction
is true in just generic
high-dimensional landscapes.
Now, the computer scientists
would say, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
Your random landscapes are a
horrible model for our error
landscapes of deep
neural networks
trained on MNIST and CIFAR-10
and so on and so forth.
You're completely
irrelevant to us,
because we're doing
something special.
We're not doing
something random.
We have a lot of structure.
OK.
The physicists might
counter, well, you know,
you just have a
high-dimensional problem.
The basic intuition
that in high dimensions
it's very hard to have
all directions curve up
at a critical point
high error should also
hold true in your problem.
OK?
But, of course, we'll
never get anywhere
if we stop there, right?
We have to move over into your
land which is also my land
and just simulate the system.
So oftentimes, you know,
biologists and computer
scientists don't
believe a theory
until they see the simulation.
So what we'll do is we'll
search for critical points
in the error landscape
of deep neural networks.
And that's what we did.
So what we did was we
used Newton's method
to find critical points.
So it turns out
that Newton's method
is attracted to saddles, right?
So Newton's method will descend
in the positive curvature
direction.
But it will ascend in the
negative curvature direction.
Because Newton's method is
gradient descent multiplied
by the inverse of the Hessian.
So if the Hessian has
a negative eigenvalue,
you take a negative
gradient and multiply it
by the negative eigenvalue,
and you turn back around
and you go uphill.
So Newton's method uncorrected
is attracted to saddle points.
OK?
So what we did was we
looked at the error
landscape of deep neural
networks trained on MNIST
and CIFAR-10, and
we just plotted
the prediction of random
landscape theory, right?
And what we found was exactly
qualitatively their prediction.
We took each critical
point and plot it
in this two-dimensional
feature space.
And we found that the
critical points concentrated
on a monotonically
increase in curve
which, again, shows
that there are
no local minima at high error.
And if your a local
minimum, your error
is close to at least the lowest
error minimum that we found.
We can't guarantee that the
lowest error minimum we found
is the global minimum.
But qualitatively,
this structure holds.
OK?
Now, the issue is what
can we do about it.
So what this is
telling us-- that even
in these problems of
practical interest,
saddle points might stand
as the major impediment
to optimization, right?
Because saddle
points can trap you.
You know, you
might go down here.
And then there might be
a very slowly curving
negative curvature direction
that might take you
a while to escape.
In fact, in the
learning dynamics
that I showed in
these transitions
in learning
hierarchical structure,
the thing controlling
the transitions
was the existence of saddle
points in weight space
of the linear neural network.
And so the part of no
learning corresponded
to sort of falling down
this direction slowly.
And then the rapid
learning corresponded--
eventually coming out this way.
OK.
So how do we do that?
Well, what we can do is we
can do a simple modification
to Newton's method,
which instead of dividing
by the Hessian, we divide by the
absolute value of the Hessian.
And, again, I should say that
this was done in collaboration
with Yoshua Bengio's lab.
And a set a fantastic graduate
students in Yoshua Bengio's lab
did all of this work on
the training and testing
of these predictions.
OK.
So what we suggested was,
you know, the offending thing
is dividing by
negative eigenvalues.
So just take the absolute
value of the Hessian, which
by definition I mean
take the Hessian,
compute its eigenvalues, and
replace each negative one
with its absolute value.
OK?
So that will obviously get
repelled by saddles, all right?
And that actually works
really, really well.
And there's a way to
derive this algorithm
in a way that makes sense,
even far from saddles
by minimizing a linear
approximation to f
within a trust region in
which the linear and quadratic
approximations agree.
OK?
So let me just show you
first that it works.
So this is the
most dramatic plot.
So basically what we did was we
did stochastic gradient descent
for a while.
And then it seemed
like the error
as a function of training time
plateaued both for a deep auto
encoder and a recurrent
neural network problem.
So when the error as a function
of training time plateaus,
that's sort of
interpreted as the fact
that you're stuck in a
local minimum, right?
But actually, when we switched
to this, what we call,
the saddle-free Newton method,
the error suddenly drops again.
So this was an illusory
signature of a local minimum.
It was actually a saddle
point with probably
a very shallow negative
curvature direction
that was hard to escape.
And when we switched to our
algorithm, we could escape it.
And, you know, what
these curves show
is that we do do better in the
final training error as while.
So now, how do we train
deep neural networks
with thousands of layers?
And actually, how do we
model complex probability
distributions?
So we want to sample from
very, very complex probability
distributions and do complex
distributional learning, right?
So this was done by
a fantastic post-doc
of mine, Jascha Sohl-Dickstein.
So we were going to Berkeley
for this non-equilibrium
statistical mechanics
meetings and things like that.
And there's been
lots of advances
in non-equilibrium
statistical mechanics
where you can show that,
roughly speaking, the second law
of thermodynamics which says
that things get more and more
disordered with time can
be transiently violated
in small systems or
short periods of time
so you can spontaneously
generate order.
OK.
So I'll just go through
this, again, very quickly.
So here's the basic idea.
Let's say you have a complicated
probability distribution.
Let's just destroy it.
Let's feed that probability
distribution through diffusion
to turn it into a simple
distribution, maybe
an isotropic Gaussian.
And we keep a record of that
destruction of structure.
And then we try to reverse
time in that process
by using deep neural networks
to reverse time and then
essentially create
structure from noise.
And then you have a very,
very simple way to sample
from complex
distributions if you
can train the neural network,
which is you just sample noise.
And you feed it through a
deterministic neural network.
And that constitutes a sample
from a complex distribution.
And so this was inspired
by recent results
in non-equilibrium stat mech.
So the basic idea,
again, is let's
imagine that you have a
very complex distribution
corresponding to
this density of dye.
You diffuse for a while.
It becomes a simpler
distribution.
Eventually, they become uniform.
You keep a [AUDIO OUT]
Now, if you
reverse process of diffusion,
you'll never go from this back
to this.
But if you reverse process a
neural network trained to do
it, you might be able to do it.
So that's the basic idea.
So that's what we did.
And I'll just show you some nice
movies to show that it works.
This is the classical toy model.
We'll go to more complex models.
This is a sample distribution
in two-dimensional space.
And so what we do is we just
systematically have the points
diffuse under Gaussian
diffusion with a restoring force
to the origin.
So the stationary distribution
of that destructive process
is an isotropic Gaussian.
OK?
And that's what happened.
So that's our training data.
The entire movie is
the training data.
OK?
Then what we do is we
train a neural network
to reverse time in that movie.
So it's a neural network with
many, many layers-- hundreds
and hundreds of layers, right?
So classically
training a network
with hundreds of layers, you
have the credit assignment
problem.
Because you don't know what
the intermediate neurons
are supposed to do.
You can circumvent the
credit assignment problem,
because each layer going
up to the next layer just
has to go from time t to time
t minus 1 in the training data.
So you have targets for all
the intermediate layers.
Therefore, you've circumvented
the credit assignment problem.
OK?
So it's relatively easy
to train such networks.
And so once you
have such a network,
what should you be able to do?
You should be able to
feed that neural network
an isotropic Gaussian, and then
have that Gaussian be turned
into the data distribution.
So that's what happens.
This on the right is
a different Gaussian.
And we just feed it through
the trained deterministic
neural network.
And out pops the structure.
It's not perfect.
There are some data
points that are over here.
But this is roughly the
distribution that it learned,
which is similar to
what it was trained on.
OK?
So now we can look at slightly
more complicated distributions.
OK.
So that's that.
So now we can train it on a toy
model of natural images, right?
So a classic toy model
of natural images
is the dead leaves
model where the sampling
process is you just throw down
circles of different radii.
So you get a complex
model of natural images
that has long range
edges, occlusion,
coherence over long length
scales, and so on and so forth.
So we can train the neural
network on such distributions.
We train it in a
convolutional fashion
by working on local
image patches.
And we convolve,
so information will
propagate over long ranges.
And so, again, we take
these natural images
and turn them into noise,
keep a record of that movie,
and then reverse
the flow of time
using a deep neural network.
OK.
So once we train that, we
should be able to turn noise
into the networks best guess
as to what a dead leaves
model would look like.
So this is what happens.
It's taking noise, and
it turns it into a gas.
OK.
So it's not a perfect model.
But it turns out log probability
of dead leaves under this
generative model that consists
of 1,000-layer deep neural
network, that's higher than
any other model so far.
So this is currently
state of the art.
OK.
And as you can see, it
gets long-range coherence
and sharp edges.
And moreover, it gets
long-range coherence
in the orientation of
[AUDIO OUT] often hard
to do in generative
models of natural images.
OK.
Now, we can actually do
something somewhat practical
with this is we can sample
from the conditional.
So then we also
trained it on textures.
OK?
So, for example,
textures of bark, right?
And we can also sample from
the conditional distribution.
So what we can do is we can
clamp the pixels outside
of a certain range,
replace the interior
with [AUDIO OUT] make it blank.
And because the network operates
in a convolutional fashion,
information from
the boundary should
propagate into the interior
and fill it in, right?
So if we look at that,
so that's white noise.
And the network
is filling it in.
And it fills in the
best guess image.
OK.
And so, again,
it's not identical
to the original image, but
it does get long-range edge
structure, coherence in the
orientation of the edge,
and smooth structure as well.
And, again, this is like
1,000-layer neural network.
Now, there's some lessons here.
OK?
Oftentimes when we model
complex data distributions, what
we try to do is we try to create
a stochastic process whose
stationery distribution is the
complex distribution, right?
Now, if your distribution
has multiple modes,
you're going to run
into a mixing problem,
because it can take a
stochastic process a long time
to jump over energy
barriers that
separate the multiple modes.
So you always have
a mixing problem.
And oftentimes when you
train probabilistic models,
you have to sample and then
the samples to train the model.
So that makes training
take a long time.
So what we're also doing in
addition to circumventing
the credit assignment
problem and training
very deep neural networks,
we're circumventing
the mixing problem in
training the generative model.
Because we're not
trying to model the data
distribution as a
stationary distribution
of a stochastic process.
That would have to run
for a very long time
to get to the
stationary distribution.
We're demanding that
during training the process
get to the data distribution in
a finite amount of time, right?
So because during training we
demand that we get to the data
distribution a finite
amount of time,
we're circumventing the mixing
problem during training.
And that's the idea.
That's [AUDIO OUT] an idea.
There's lots of
results now that show
that you can attain information
about stationary equilibrium
distributions from
non-equilibrium trajectories.
OK.
So now, I'm done.
So let's see.
OK.
So there's that.
So, again, you
can read about all
of this stuff in
this set of papers.
Again, I'd like to thank
my funding and just
the key players.
So Andrew Saxe, you know,
did the work with me
on non-linear learning
dynamics and learning
hierarchical category structure.
Jascha Sohl-Dickstein
did the work
on deep learning using
non-equilibrium thermodynamics.
And the work on saddle points
was a nice collaboration
with Yoshua Bengio's lab.
And again-- fantastic
graduate students
in Yoshua Bengio's lab.
OK.
So I think there's
a lot more to do
in terms of unifying
neuroscience, machine
learning, physics, math,
statistics, all of that stuff.
It'll keep us busy
for the next century.